THOSE CRITICAL SUPPLIES.
WATCH THE PRESIDENT.
>> THESE STUPID SUPPLY CHAINS
ALL OVER THE WORLD, WE HAVE A
SUPPLY CHAIN WHERE THEY ARE MADE
IN ALL DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE
WORLD, AND ONE LITTLE PIECE OF
THE WORLD GOES BAD AND THE WHOLE
THING IS MESSED UP.
I SAID, "WE SHOULDN’T HAVE
SUPPLY CHAINS, WE SHOULD HAVE
THEM ALL IN THE UNITED STATES."
WE HAVE THE COMPANIES TO DO IT.
IF WE DON’T, WE CAN DO THAT.
>> Harris: JOINING ME NOW IS
WHITE HOUSE CHECKED ON MY TRADE
ADVISOR PETER NAVARRO.
YOU KNOW QUITE A BIT ABOUT ALL
OF THIS EQUIPMENT.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING ME TODAY
ON THE PROGRAM.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, HARRIS.
YES, INDEED, WE CAN MAKE THIS AN
AMERICA PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN
TALKING ABOUT SINCE JUNE IN
PENNSYLVANIA 2016 AS A
CANDIDATE.
BRING THIS STUFF HOME.
I FIND IT HIGHLY IRONIC THAT
YOU’VE GOT BRIGHT UP THERE ON
CAPITOL HILL ISSUING THESE DIRE
WARNINGS ON THE VERY DAY
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS GOING TO THE
BEAUTIFUL LEHIGH VALLEY TO
ANNOUNCE A TOUGHER, SMARTER,
MORE RESILIENT STRATEGIC
NATIONAL STOCKPILE.
I CALL IT THE SNS 2.0.
WHAT IT’S GOING TO BE IS A
BIGGER STOCKPILE THAT IS SPREAD
NOT JUST IN FEMA WHERE HOUSES
BUT DISTRIBUTION CENTERS.
THE POINT OF CARE HOSPITALS ARE
GOING TO CARRY MORE INVENTORY.
AS WE BRING OUR SUPPLY CHAINS
AND PRODUCTION HOME, OUR
FACTORIES ARE GOING TO HAVE
RESERVE CAPACITY THAT CAN
QUICKLY RAMP UP TO MEET OUR
DEMANDS.
IN CASE WE HAVE A SECOND WAVE IN
THE FALL.
I THOUGHT BRIGHT’S "SKY IS
FALLING" WARNING REALLY WASN’T
IMPORTING WITH REALITY, BOOTS ON
THE GROUND.
>> Harris: PETER, YOU BROUGHT
IT UP, LET’S SHOW THE VIEWERS
WHAT YOU’RE TALKING ABOUT AND
THEN I WILL GET YOUR REACTION.
HERE IS DR. BRIGHT, FROM TODAY.
>> I WILL NEVER FORGET THE
EMAILS I RECEIVED FROM MIKE
BOWEN, INDICATING THAT WE ARE
--DASH THE AND 90 RESPIRATOR
SUPPLIER WAS COMPLETELY
DECIMATED.
HE SAID, "WE ARE IN DEEP SLEEP.
THE WORLD IS.
WE NEED TO ACT."
I PUSH THAT FORWARD TO THE
HIGHEST LEVELS I COULD IN HHS.
I GOT NO RESPONSE.
>> Harris: PETER?
>> THE RESPONSE FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE, FROM THE DAY
PRESIDENT TRUMP BAND OF FLIGHTS
FROM CHINA ON JANUARY 30TH, THIS
WHITE HOUSE WAS OFF AND RUNNING
ON THREE DIFFERENT VECTORS OF
ATTACK.
THE HORSE RACE FOR VACCINE
DEVELOP MEN, THE RAPID DEVELOP
MEANT OF THERAPEUTICS LIKE
REMDESIVIR, AND THE RAPID
PRODUCTION OF THINGS LIKE N95
MASKS.
FROM THAT POINT ON TILL TODAY, Y
HAVE PROGRESS ON ALL THOSE
FRIENDS, INCLUDING THE ADDITION
OF OVER 2 BILLION MASKS
CAPACITY IN THIS COUNTRY IN A
YEAR.
HERE’S THE THING -- IF YOU
LISTEN CAREFULLY TO THE BRIGHT
TESTIMONY, AND HIS COMPLAINT,
THERE ARE TWO THINGS -- HE’S NOT
JUST A DISGRUNTLED EMPLOYEE, IN
MY JUDGMENT.
HE IS A DESERTER IN THE WAR ON
THE CHINA VIRUS.
WHY DO I SAY THAT?
THOSE ARE HARSH WORDS.
HE HAD A CHANCE.
HE WAS ASKED TO GO OVER TO NIH
AND LEAD A BILLION-DOLLAR
INITIATIVE TO GET TESTING TO THE
PEOPLE OF AMERICA, AND HE
REFUSED TO DO THAT.
I AM A CONSCRIPT IN THE ARMY, AN
FOR THE VIRUS HIT I WAS
DOING TRADE DEALS TO TRY AND
BRING MANUFACTURING HOME.
WE SHOULD BE DOING WHAT WE’RE
DOING.
HERE’S THE OTHER THING, HARRIS.
THIS IS REALLY INTERESTING,
ABOUT THE BRIGHT COMPLAINT.
IF YOU LOOK AT IT VERY
CAREFULLY --
>> Harris: I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT CHINA, WE NEED TO GET TO
IT.
GO AHEAD.
>> HE’S COMPLAINING, BASICALLY,
THAT HE KNEW IT ALL AND WE WERE
DOING ANYTHING.
WELL, GUESS WHAT?
FROM FEBRUARY 2ND, WHEN I
EXCHANGED SOME EMAILS WITH HIM
AND HAD THEM OVER TO HIS OFFICE,
AND WE WORKED WITH HHS, WE WERE
ABLE TO ACCELERATE ALL OF THESE
THINGS.
VACCINE DEVELOPMENT,
THERAPEUTICS, AND MASKS, ON
BEHALF OF THIS WHITE HOUSE, AT
THE DIRECTION OF THIS
WHITE HOUSE.
SO, THE IDEA THAT THIS
WHITE HOUSE WASN’T MOVING AS
FAST AS IT COULD FROM
JANUARY 30TH, WHEN THE PRESIDENT
TOOK THAT COURAGEOUS DECISION,
THIS IS POLITICS.
THIS IS A DISGRUNTLED OBAMA
EMPLOYEE ON THE HILL.
WHEN I HEAR HER TALK ABOUT
BLAMING THE TRUMPET
ADMINISTRATION AND LETTING CHINA
OFF THE HOOK FOR BRINGING THIS
PANDEMIC DOWN, THIS PLAGUE UPON
THE WORLD, THAT’S WRONG.
>> Harris: THAT’S WHERE I WANT
TO GO, LET’S GO TO THAT.
BY THE WAY, THE HHS SECRETARY
AZAR WAS WITH THE PRESIDENT A
SHORT TIME AGO BEFORE THEY WERE
HEADED TO PENNSYLVANIA, AND SAID
SOME OF THE SAME THINGS ABOUT
WHAT THOSE MEETINGS WITH
DR. BRIGHT WERE LIKE.
HE’S ON THE HILL TESTIFYING HIS
VERSION RIGHT NOW.
LET’S GET TO THIS.
"TENSIONS BETWEEN THE U.S. AND
CHINA.
PETER, THEY ARE GROWING OVER
COVID-19.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS BEIJING
CANNOT USE THE PANDEMIC AS AN
EXCUSE TO WALK AWAY FROM THEIR
PHASE ONE TRADE DEAL.
LET’S WATCH THAT TOGETHER.
>> THEY’D LIKE TO RENEGOTIATE
THE DEAL.
WE ARE GOING TO RENEGOTIATE.
LOOK, I’M NOT HAPPY ABOUT
ANYTHING HAVING TO DO WITH THAT
PARTICULAR SUBJECT RIGHT NOW.
>> HAVE YOU SPOKEN TO
XI JINPING?
>> HAVE A VERY GOOD
RELATIONSHIP, BUT I JUST --
RIGHT NOW I DON’T WANT TO SPEAK
TO HIM.
>> Harris: PETER NAVARRO, THE
PRESIDENT DOESN’T WANT TO TALK
TO CHINA’S PRESIDENT.
WHAT’S HAPPENING?
>> WELL, LET’S GO THROUGH THE
TIMELINE.
NOVEMBER, CHINA SPAWNS THE
VIRUS, PROBABLY IN THAT WEAPONS
LAB IN WUHAN, HIDES THE VIRUS
FOR TWO MONTHS BEHIND A SHIELD
OF THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION, AS IT DOES THIS,
ACCORDING TO
THEIR OWN DATA, THEY VACUUMED UP
ALL OF THE PPE ACROSS THE WORLD,
INCLUDING FROM HERE.
BASICALLY HOARDED IT, KEPT IT
FROM OUR DOCTORS AND NURSES IN
MILAN AND NEW YORK AND
EVERYWHERE IN BETWEEN, KILLING
PEOPLE BECAUSE OF THAT.
THEN, AFTERWARDS, THEY BASICALLY
ARE PROFITEERING NOW FROM IT.
HERE’S WHAT -- RIGHT NOW, THE
HACKERS FROM THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT ARE TRYING TO STEAL
THE VACCINE INFORMATION SO THEY
CAN MAKE IT FIRST AND --
>> Harris: PETER, WHAT ARE WE
GOING TO DO ABOUT IT?
>> WELL, WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO
ABOUT IT?
WHAT WE NEED TO DO RIGHT NOW,
AND WHAT I’M FOCUSING ON, IS
MAKING SURE THAT WE MAKE STUFF
IN AMERICA.
THIS IS THE DOBBS PRESIDENT, THE
MANUFACTURING PRESIDENT, THE
INNOVATION PRESIDENT, AND THE ON
SHORING PRESIDENT.
HARRIS, THIS IS A WAKE-UP CALL.
>> Harris: AND THAT PRESIDENT
IS LANDING RIGHT NOW.
FORGIVE ME, IT’S HARD WITH THE
DELAY.
I DON’T MEAN TO BE IMPOLITE, TO
CUT IN.
BUT I WANT THE AUDIENCE TO LOOK
AT THE SCREEN.
THE PRESIDENT NOW HAS ARRIVED IN
ALLENTOWN, PENNSYLVANIA.
YOU KNOW, THIS IS A POINT, TOO,
WHERE THERE ARE JOBS THAT THAT
PLANT.
PEOPLE ARE AT THAT DISTRIBUTION
CENTER, PETER, AND THEY HAVE
JOBS.
THE PRESIDENT HAS HAD A TOUGH
WEEK WITH REGARD TO THAT.
WE HAVE SOME 36 MILLION WHO HAVE
NOW, IN THE PAST FEW WEEKS,
APPLIED FOR UNEMPLOYMENT.
AS THE PRESIDENT PULLS INTO VIEW
IN ALLENTOWN, PENNSYLVANIA, TO
GO VISIT THAT DISTRIBUTION
CENTER THAT IS BRINGING PPE FROM
OVERSEAS TO THE UNITED STATES.
JUST TALK WITH ME IF YOU CAN
ABOUT WHERE WE ARE WITH THIS
ECONOMY AND WHAT IS NEXT.
TRADE WAS YOUR AREA OF
EXPERTISE.
THE ECONOMY, TOO.
THE PRESIDENT NOW ON THE GROUND,
IN AIR FORCE ONE.
>> MITTS LET’S MAKE IT CLEAR THA
DISTRIBUTE AND CENTER IS
BRINGING IN MASKS AND PPE, ALSO
NOW MADE IN AMERICA.
>> Harris: OKAY.
>> WE STOOD UP TWO AND 95 MASS
PLANTS IN FIVE WEEKS,
RHODE ISLAND AND ARIZONA.
WE GOT THE NATIONAL COUNCIL OF
TEXTILE ORGANIZATIONS BRINGING
TOGETHER COMPANIES LIKE HAYNES,
FRUIT OF THE LOOM.
THEY ARE MAKING GOWNS, MASKS,
AND ALL OF THAT.
WE ARE BRINGING THAT HOME.
THAT DISTRIBUTION CENTER NOT
ONLY IS EMPLOYING PEOPLE IN
PENNSYLVANIA, BY DISTRIBUTING
THAT PPE IS GOING TO HELP
WORKERS BE ABLE TO WORK SAFELY
IN WORKPLACES.
DOCTORS AND NURSES WORK SAFELY
TO PROTECT THE PEOPLE.
THAT IS WHAT WE HAVE TO DO.
WHEN YOU ASK THE QUESTION, WOULD
YOU BE GOOD DON’T LIKE TO
GOING FORWARD?
WE HAVE TO MOVE FROM A SERVICE
SECTOR ECONOMY.
WE WILL LOSE SOME OF THAT IN
THIS PANDEMIC, TO MANUFACTURING
ECONOMY.
THAT IS WHAT THIS PRESENT IS
FOCUSED ON.
>> Harris: I HEAR YOU.
>> THIS IS THE MANUFACTURING
JOBS PRESIDENT.
WE HAVE TO MAKE IT HERE, BRING
THE SUPPLY CHAIN’S HOME.
NOT JUST FOR PHARMACEUTICALS,
NOT JUST FOR MEDICAL SUPPLIES
AND EQUIPMENT, IT’S GOING TO BE
FOR EVERYTHING.
WE ARE GOING TO PROSPER AND
GROW.
LET ME SAY ONE LAST THING, IF I
HAVE A MINUTE.
>> Harris: ALL RIGHT.
PICO 17 DAYS IN KOKOMO, INDIANA,
THE MIRACLE
THAT POINTS TO AMERICA’S FUTURE.
WHAT WAS IT?
GM, A BIG COMPANY, WORKING WITH
THE VENTILATOR COMPANY.
BOOM, THEY MADE VENTILATORS IN
17 DAYS, THROUGH AMERICAN
INNOVATION.
THAT IS AMERICA’S FUTURE.
JOBS, JOBS, JOBS UNDER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Harris: ALL RIGHT.
LET’S STOP THERE.
I’M GOING TO HAVE YOU BACK, IF
YOU WILL JOIN ME AGAIN ON
ANOTHER DAY.
LET’S TALK MORE.
THE PRESIDENT ON THE GROUND IN
ALLENTOWN, PENNSYLVANIA.
GLAD YOU WERE WITH ME, PETER, AS
THIS WAS HAPPENING.
BECAUSE THAT IS YOUR LANE,
KNOWING WHAT IS GOING ON WITH